[Music]
and speaking of politics he's 28 feet
tall and only bathes once a year that's
right Jane the Lincoln Memorial has been
undergoing its annual cleaning so I'm
heading to DC I check in with the people
down there that are involved the project
very exciting stuff what fun
don't forget to pack your long johns
Danny OH
so until tomorrow I'm Jay in the cave
and I'm Danny see you in the tomorrow
and record
see you in the tomorrow what's catchy
this season on HBO's v-point one of its
main characters plays an anchor on a
fictional version of CBS this morning
this is so on Monday
fiction meets real-life actor Reed Scott
who plays actor Dan Egan will be here in
studio 57 and he announced on Twitter
you will join us at the real table right
here in studio 57 money I get such a
kick because they didn't ask us anything
about doing it but they use our graphics
they use a lot of our story bars I think
it's very cool I know and even you know
charlie didn't Charlie cover the
cleaning of the Washington Monument -
I'm like giddy no I'm joking
what is this storyline that's very good
oh I missed that